- I think that this is really cool though
and we like, I love teachers so much.
My mama was a teacher, I
think they are just the angels
walking around on planet Earth.
And, I think they do so much and they're,
they're, you know underpaid,
there's a lot going on there.
- [Others Off Camera] Absolutely.
- But I find this amazing
that you were a teacher
for 10 years before rapping,
- [D Smoke] Yes. Yes.
- like before this all happened.
That's amazing.
- [D Smoke] Seven full years
and then when I found
myself transitioning,
(audience clapping)
I was like all right
Imma substitute teach.
- [Jane Lynch] That's like Sting,
- That's really cool.
- [Jane Lynch] Sting
was an English teacher
before he was Sting.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Really?
I didn't know that.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I have gotta be honest,
I didn't have teachers looking like y'all.
- [Jane Lynch] I know.
(everyone laughing)
- [D Smoke] I didn't.
- I wanna be looking cool.
I was like, I was like.
My teachers were cool, I'm sorry.
But I just meant y'all look like so,
I can't imagine like,
Sting and D Smoke like being my teacher.
I'd be like, I would pay
attention. I would learn.
I think that would be so cool.
I'd just want to look cool in your eyes.
So I would have like practiced anything.
But your, your career has
blown up though since then.
So I don't know, you said
you considered yourself
and I love this, you said you
considered yourself successful
before, like getting what "people",
what society calls successful.
What do you, what do you mean
by that? I think I know, but.
- Well, there wasn't a day
that I went into the classroom
and didn't know that what
I was doing meant something
or that it, that what I was
doing counted, you know?
And I think a lot of times people,
(Audience clapping)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah
clap for that. Yeah.
- A lot of times people have careers.
You know, where they make
a lot of money, you know,
and they're successful in
a lot of people's views,
but then they question like,
what did it all mean afterwards?
And there, there's no day
when you leave the classroom,
and like, what, what did that mean?
You know, there are some days
where you left the classroom
and you're like, okay,
I got beat up today.
Like I lost.
- Children are evil.
- Students won. I didn't win today,
but tomorrow I've got it you know.
But, but it all counted.
Whether it was a really difficult day or
it was like one of those
fun ones where it's like,
oh, we're all on the same team. You know?
So in that sense I was
successful. And at the same time,
you know, I wasn't making the
kind of money I make now, but,
you know, I was for sure
comfortable, I could drive.
I could, you know, have
a roof over my head
and eat and pay my bills,
you know? So, and it,
and it informed the rapper
that I am today that, you know,
the community, you know, leader
that I can be now, you know?
So teaching was the real
experience that was real life.
(Audience clapping)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah
absolutely I also think its,
I always tell artists this on the voice,
that come on the voice
and I'm everybody always
thinks success is, oh,
if you blow up and
you're like, the biggest,
I'm like success to me as an artist
is you can pay your bills
with doing what you love.
Like, not everybody who
blows up in that way,
but are you going to be able to like,
make money doing what you love?
Absolutely that can happen.
So it's just how you gauge
and like what success means.
(Audience clapping)
I think we all think
it's you gotta be like,
as famous as a Kardashian
to be successful.
- Well, that's the thing
I think is that we've for,
kids these days, you put
the cart before the horse
and you want a certain
amount of subscribers,
you want a certain amount of likes
and it's before you have
even cultivated what it is
that you do, that makes you happy,
that, that you can give to the world via.
- Which is a disservice to yourself.
- [Jane Lynch] It really is.
That's kind of the hard thing. Go ahead.
- Totally. I was just
saying we compare insides
to other people's outsides and it's, it's,
it's a bad way to do.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh wow. Well said.
- [Jane Lynch] 1990s therapy.
- I'm gonna process that later.
- Yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- I'm taking that with me.
- I heard it from somebody else,
so I stole it, you steal it. Seriously.